لا عيدا في استقبال زائر ولا حديثا
مستعجلا عند الوداع قست الجدران على
صاحبها في قلبها سواد دمار لا غير يتعرف
هذا الرجل على منزل تغيرت ملامحه انقلب
راسا على عقب
والارض لا تسعه وان مدت له يد العون
حديث الرصاص في صباحات العيد احتفظ المكان
بالادله قذيفه ورصاصات طائشه يخمن محمود
الطيب تفاصيل ما حل بمنزله وسط العديد في
العاصمه الخرطوم
في الحديد فوق الجزاز الجزاز بتاع العربيه
وهنا في قطاع كده من الحديد ضربت هنا وبعد
المسافه دي
الدوريهم حادثه بيت مدمر نجحوا الى ولايات
سودانيه مجاوره بعيدا عن ساحه الصراع بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
مئات السودانيين نزحوا الى ولايات مجاوره
للخرطوم شمالا وجنوبا مناطق وان كانت
بعيده نسبيا عن الاشتباكات الا ان خارطه
المعارك تنذر بامتداد الصراع محتدم الى
اطراف الخرطوم وابعد غيداء السالم العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات